The Millennium Development Goals,
Gavin,
I support for poverty reduction
today,
the target of housing,
the number of people living in extreme
poverty has been met.
Progress has been uneven
as the United Nations and its partners
shape a new global framework to replace
the mdgs in 2015.
They faced the challenge of ending
poverty for good,
which means tackling some important
questions.
What is poverty?
How is it measured?
Poverty is not only the income and poor
people do not live only in poor
countries
today,
a new bottom billion live in middle
income countries,
including India and China.
It's also not just a question of getting
to zero,
but staying there.
Then there's the issue of where to fix
the new development goal posts to
recapture the Millennium Declarations
vision.
The new international development agenda
must embody principles of solidarity,
equality,
dignity and respect for nature.
Finally,
once these goals have been agreed,
how will they be achieved?
We'll need new policies and leadership
by national governments and the global
community,
but what else?
On the fifth of December,
2013,
we debated these questions and others
with the panel of world experts kick
here to watch the arguments.